- It's Fall, bitches.
Let's make some leaf crafts.
- Decoupaged?
Is that a real word?
- What the fuck does decoupage mean?
- Decoupage, bro.
- I can't wait for Christmas.
I love that pine tree smell.
These leaves smell like nothing.
- See, this is why guys
don't use Pinterest
cause I don't even want to read this.
- Yeah.
We don't need these instructions,
we're just gonna go for it.
- This looks like a
big triumphant bastard,
I don't know if I want this one.
- I'm gonna do my twine first.
- I do like this sponge brush though.
- Yeah, this is nice.
- There's dust everywhere.
Rope dust.
- There's gotta be more to this, right?
It's like, it's not just
gluing leaves to a jar.
Is that it man?
- I don't know man,
It's kind of therapeutic.
- I like peeling the Modge
Podge from my fingers,
after it dries.
- You know, I'm not mad at this.
- You know what,
what if I just wrapped
twine around all of it.
Like on a shipwreck or something.
- Like a shipwreck.
- Like a ship.
- So did I win the mason jar.
(laughter)
- You suck.
- Thanks.
- But you tried.
- Decoupaging is an art.
You need to be very delicate.
And we were not that delicate.
- No.
- I would definitely not put
a picture of this on Pinterest
and be like, "Look what I made."
- Fuck that, dude.
I would stand like this,
with the jar like that on Pinterest,
and one of these smiles like.
How the fuck does this work?
Like this?
- What even is this?
- No one has ever ever needed this.
- Cut the bag in three strips.
- I'm just gonna start cutting.
- Is he cutting it the wrong direction.
- Weak men have doubts before decision.
Strong men have doubts after.
- You look like you work
at In In-N-Out, dude.
- I'm down, that's good.
- We'll I'm gonna make
one that fits my head.
- This is a really bored drunk mom
who came up with this like,
"I don't know, I just like
"take some bags and glue leaves to them
"and put them on your heads."
- Did you,
Okay, I was about to say,
"If you took my leaf.
"Something awful this way comes."
- Would it be terrible if
we like ended our friendhip
and broke into a fight
over making leaf hats.
- I need two of the same color.
Let me get some reds though.
- Hold on, lemme just
make it rain on you here.
- I made my crown for you.
- I made mine for you.
- Is it on properly.
Doesn't fit.
- Strange.
- I crown you Pinterest All Star Zachary.
- How do you do that?
T.I. must have velcro on his head.
- Yeah, dude.
- Cause his hat's all the way back here.
- Hair clips.
- Yeah, there's no way this stays on.
(camera shutter)
- It's not bad.
We did an alright job.
- This one is the first one that actually
seems like something you could use
and not be laughed at.
- Tap into the little
hunter/gatherer inside of you
and forge for leaves throughout
your yard and neighborhood.
- Practice on an old cloth napkin.
Don't need to do that.
- Choose a leaf and turn it over
so the more veiny side is facing up.
- I feel like I should
get some of this at home.
- I like this hack.
This is cool.
- This one is so much easier.
Turn your leaf over and
carefully position it
on your cloth napkin
however you'd like it.
- Oh.
- Now this, this is what
she doesn't tell you,
but this is the most
important part, for sure.
- I feel like Mission Impossible,
and I'm Tom Cruise and
I can't touch the floor.
- I'm feeling good.
I feel good
- You feel good?
- I feel like once I unveil this,
it's gonna look real nice.
- Oh, it's slipping.
I got you, I got you.
See, this is why you need a bro
when you Pinterest.
- I mean, you can see.
It's more subtle.
- Yeah, it's more subtle.
- More experimental.
- Yeah.
- Dope.
I like it.
- Looks like a Sponge Bob
Square Pants character.
- I want to make a turkey
and have all of my family and friends over
to come look at my napkins
cause they're so cute.
- I think Pinterest is cool.
I think it's an interesting place
to share creative ideas.
- I would love make some leaf crowns
with like, my little cousins.
That would be awesome.
- Actually, you know,
this would be really good,
this would be good
to do with your mom on Mother's Day.
Like, if I did this for my mom,
actually, my mom would hate this shit.
(laughter)
- I would rather make it myself
than buy it at a store.
- Yeah, I agree.
I could get on with that.
- Lakers lost again.
- Catching the game.
Yeah, dude, right.
- They lost again.
- Doesn't surprise me, man.
It's been a bad few years.
Although, they have
fucking Stoudemire now.
- No, the Lakers' don't have Stoudemire.
- They don't have Stoudemire?
Who has Stoudemire?
Oh, it's the Cavs, right?
- I think Stoudemire's done, dude.
- Oh, it's Kobe's last year.
- Really? Good.
- Fuck you, man.
(laughter)